what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today if you clicked on
this video be sure to leave a like uh
yeah we're working on peacemaker right
now in our uncharted review at 3 30 in
the morning and we're like let's take a
little break to watch this batman clip
that was apparently released on jimmy
kimmel haven't seen it yet but of course
it's a clip from the batman we gotta
check it out be sure to look out for our
review when it comes out just a couple
weeks whenever we end up watching this
movie let's get to it people
[Music]
who's the mustache with the broken nose
that's kenzie narcotics
he's one of the guys that got into it
with the iceberg lounge
what are you saying kenzie moonlights
for the penguin
oh i'm online just a cop
moonlight is a cop that's good
[Applause]
oh damn this is gonna be so cool
come
on
what did you do
dude holy crap i love all the locked off
shots they're doing to like really put
you connected with his gear and his
motions and all that stuff there's
something just so visually great about
something as simple as seeing him run
through the police station and actually
see the cape moving around where we know
so much of like nowadays you gotta like
cgi the cape on it look it feels like
really natural and it's cool to behold
and just the tension and the mood of
this just feels like just classic noir
detective mystery throughout every
single percolating moment of this i just
adore it so much and like he hits gordon
we don't know why there's no surrounding
context before this like before we watch
this i was like okay let's see if like
robert pattinson sets up the clip i only
watched like 30 seconds before they
played the clip and i was like he's not
setting up the clip
so i don't know what's going on but i
love like
just the the level of actually you know
i screenshotted this thing on my phone
sometimes i get these quotes that i just
i just love hearing about from the
batman jeffrey wright was talking and he
said there's an awareness of instability
within gotham that i think is reflective
of the times there's an awareness of
certain class tension and pervasive
distrust in gotham in the way that matt
shaped the riddler here it speaks to a
kind of present-day virality that we use
for communication of certain ideas and
propaganda
and already in this one clip alone that
level of distrust you can really feel
uh the tensions rising within gotham pd
and i love like just the level of
reclusiveness and pure isolation of just
batman workings alone with gordon and
like he only trusts gordon
and obviously he punches him not because
he's like mad at him
i can't think of time i've ever seen him
punch gordon before which is kind of
like jarring because like not even
gordon seemed like he saw it coming yet
so he just takes out his frustrations
throughout the movie just sucker
punching people left and right yeah but
also trying to investigate like who in
the gcpd is one of worthy of trusting
like i love that line the dialogue
exchange of like you think he moonlights
for penguin he probably moonlights as a
cop like oh wow
well yeah and i mean i love that they're
drawing this you know iteration of the
gcpd like there's always some element of
yeah there are crooked cops and there
are straight cops but here it's like
even just being in the building is like
you're in another cave somewhere and you
feel all these prying eyes everyone's
looking through the window everyone
wants to know probably what gordon and
batman are talking about and yeah like
as much as there is the rogues gallery
and the crime of gotham it's just as
tense to watch him have to navigate you
know the gcpd and i imagine this is
probably going to be a significant
moment where like the entire police
force is going to be after him and it's
funny because there's that shot in the
trailer where they're all swarming on
him and they're all like getting into a
big old dogfight and it looks like it's
in that same holding room there so i
wonder
when this happens in relation to that
but either way yeah it feels like a very
spontaneous
off-the-cuff kind of moment befitting of
a batman who has to kind of think on his
feet and who maybe isn't quite as
experienced yet so maybe he needs to
create some sort of down and dirty
diversion to you know get out and get on
to the next part of whatever the
investigation is the diversion seems to
be to protect gordon actually yeah
ultimately because it seems like all the
cops are after batman and if he's seen
working with batman directly like gordon
obviously that's just the way the
relationship forms the impression that i
got of why he hit him is to show that
they're not or at least to have the
optics surrounding the situation between
the dynamic of gordon is not in league
with batman anymore so batman punches
him in order to make it look like then
no they're not working together yeah and
then also probably from there we can see
what are the other cops gonna do what's
the guy who they've been talking about
directly going to do in wake of this
maybe this will bring some information
gordon's way in the process depending on
how the rest of the you know officers
respond because obviously yeah like that
brings everybody to a kinship
again with gordon and not having a
reason to suspect him in that moment and
there seems to be such a realism about
the way the scene is executed and i
think that makes it so exciting because
like they just have that great giachino
score that's just like what is that
instrument well it's like they're
plucking just like that's a
like violin or or cello plucks and yeah
it's like it's creeping it's got that
staccato quality like it's literally
sneaking around in the shadows behind
you and it doesn't become bombastic in
that moment like it's something about
batman just being a fugitive within the
police station running around and it
just feels realistic that he just sticks
out the grappling hook shoots it up
there and you just watch him ascend
feels so real like this is feeling like
everything that we've been hearing
teased about i think that's what's so
exciting is not only to see the trailers
for this here the filmmakers and cast
talk about this movie and then to get
two clips so far
that really feel reflective of
everything that they've been saying
they're going for it's just so uh
awesome to behold and um i think that's
why i'm eating it up so much yeah uh i'm
having a hard time believing that i'm
not gonna like this roof i know i feel
like i've already become so biased that
i can't believe it's already almost here
like every time i think about it somehow
still feels like it's a year and change
away yeah you know but yeah this is
gorgeous guys uh what did you think
about this clip for the batman leave
your thoughts down below why do you
think he ended up punching gordon
himself
um yeah it's exciting exciting even got
a display recently
uh for
for batman
just to honor honor the times and uh
subscribe hit that bell last night at
least so paige
you're the catwoman of this channel you
are the selena kyle of the real rejects
jumping from rooftop to rooftop pulling
us in to your intrigue and your mystery
enlightening us of things may be pushing
us toward our limits but fox we would be
nothing without you you give us
confidence but you also bring out the
justice within us and you could probably
kick the both of our asses or at least
mine and that's something that i don't
take lightly you know i appreciate your
power your strength your brutality now
i'm not i'm not gonna go that far you
still have that sense of what is right
you're not gonna be you know like
a vengeance now you're more calculated
than that you are more
sensuous than that much like a cat so
fox even though that's a canine animal
variant i'm still sticking to this
simile here because uh foxes are still
graceful you know there's still light on
their feet and they still have an air of
mystery you know so uh you touch it
i am now in jesus christ
later fox
[Music]